[Music]
alright man I'm on Runyon up an old
Runyon Canyon and I just had the
weirdest thing happened to me you know
I'm not like butch dude by any stretch
of the imagination but I got into a
fight Runyon Canyon
it didn't I'm walking shaggy like hold
on just to make her part of this there
Shecky on a leash okay this is a leash
list but you know there's a certain part
of the park where you take your dog off
the leash if I leave my dog on a leash
cuz you know you don't want to start no
[ __ ]
this is dude this who walks dogs up
Runyon Canyon and when I say dogs I mean
eight or nine at a clip here he comes
I'm about to run into him I must spend a
camera around so you could see him
that's right keep them tame keep them
tame dude I'm sure your good guy too but
like I got one dog on a leash how many
dogs you got on a leash done and done
you know what in the spirit of things
okay I'd shake I agree I agree they're
good dogs Tim but like to be fair
there's one dog and there's this may
dogs even if he's a puppy it's like you
know
we don't need to go through this again I
appreciate the [ __ ] gesture Kevin man
how are you pleasure Tim I don't envy
you this task will talk as we pass yes
we try don't we Tim we both love dogs
pleasure man look man look at that piece
[ __ ] piece like I was so mad like
come coming up the hill my dog and his
dogs met his dog went after my dog and
his dog wasn't on a leash and you know I
was trying to like keep Shecky from
getting bit and then like you know I
threw out there like leash your dog man
like not even that shitty and like it
triggered him in a big bad way I think
and then we got this screaming fight all
the way up Runyon at each other where I
was whoa well done we almost went down
where I was like more hostile than I've
been in [ __ ] years man oh I was I
said he was triggered
I was triggered myself because I was
like man I got one [ __ ] dog he got
like nine unleashes and some of them
aren't on leashes and the one that I on
a leash attack the dog and he's like
it's a puppy I'm like it don't [ __ ]
matter like you know maybe walk him like
one at a time or whatever but anyway I
steamin like cuz we kept yelling at each
other and cuz he was going it's a it's a
leashless park mate and I was Jana from
the tip of the canyon it's a leash let's
park make so then when I got up to the
top normally I just keep walking but I
was like I'm gonna turn around today I'm
gonna walk down the hill with my dogs
I'm gonna run back into that guy because
I'm not done gonna [ __ ] a piece of my
mind
and that's what I intended to do was
like you know [ __ ] be like dude I
thought about it more in the fact that
you've got was doing the math you've got
now eight or nine dogs like a one dog
blah blah blah and instead
old Tim completely disarmed me with
peace bro peace he was just like we
don't need to do this I'm a good guy
you're a good guy clearly we're both
good guys we're like dogs and we settled
our brief just differences that's in
that [ __ ] sweet you just saw that
happen in real time man that's nuts very
human moment involving lots of nonhumans
and I'm not talking about the dogs you
should have heard me and Tim yelling at
each other
he'll [ __ ] a lot you know that's me
saying it but regardless man he reached
out with the olive branch you know maybe
it's cuz I live video going but whatever
that's that's what's possible kids
compromise understanding you know
[ __ ] tolerance I think I learned
something today forty nine and then I
learned something come on shaky this is
all your fault that's what I learned
blame somebody else
[ __ ] rolls downhill him blame Chuckie
for all that there it is
human adventure we took folks you saw it
happen live and [ __ ]
Shia that had won everyone to have a
great day I'm gonna have one now that my
day was [ __ ] after that encounter I
was so I was gonna carry it around all
steamy and [ __ ] and now I'm walking with
a spring in my step man like I can't
believe I'm gonna say this cuz I was not
gonna say this on the way down but be
like Tim the whole walk up I was like
[ __ ] Tim now I'm like be like Tim man
[ __ ] and Tim was much better than
apologizing that was if you heard I
didn't even [ __ ] come out with an
apology I was still nursing and
righteous anger self-righteous anger but
tiny man I'm glad I met Tim let's see
him again
and his pack of wild dogs there all to
him for just kidding
hey don't forget Jane song about
rebooting rebooting got your tickets
we've added a bunch of new shows because
a lot of shows sold out next week
we gave to that we announce all the
January to March dates where you come
see us any place is not represented yet
gonna be represented then when we
release dates all right man
reboot Roadshow calm is the address or
go to Jay and Silent Bob calm you could
cool shirts like this yeah look at that
chain saw Bob [ __ ]
reboot logo shirt available in black and
white at Jay's on Bob secret stash Jay
and Silent Bob calm there it is folks
enough selling [ __ ] we're selling peace
which we just saw happen give peace a
chance I just coined that phrase
nobody's ever said that before we'll put
that [ __ ] on the t-shirt have a great
day kids
you